let's go to marcos from florida marcos
from florida you were next on today
hey dave hey um i've been uh i've just
been hearing you about some candidates
uh that could be you know for for
election in 2024 yeah i think they gotta
be related to uh the january six
committee
uh because they're gonna pick a
republican that's all crazy
supporting january 6 and it would be
great if one of the one of them will be
a candidate for uh the democrats now
jamie raskin is my favorite he's got
great comebacks
and he's really knowledgeable
uh
and uh he's got a bunch of support
from different groups yeah
and you know
i'm not sure what religion he's he is
but i think yeah
from non-religious people well here's
the thing with raskin marcos so let let
me mention i think jamie raskin is
extremely smart
fantastic public speaker has done an
incredible job with the trump
impeachment
you know years ago and he i think he's a
fascinating guy
um i think that he
is going to have an issue
because he is jewish i think that there
are people who don't want i mean there's
anti-semitism in the u.s on the right
and on the left and i think jamie raskin
among other reasons may have a little
bit of an uphill battle because he is
jewish but i think he's an interesting
guy i just don't i just don't see him as
even running to be perfectly honest
yeah i think jamie is as jewish for uh
race but not necessarily
a jewish believer
well you know you've opened up a very
important question that's a that's the
vast majority of jews i mean the jews in
the united states who are of course
ethnically jewish as you're pointing out
many don't literally believe the
teachings i i am one such person you
know i'm not a religious person at all
but i identify with the jewish community
and ethnicity and culture yeah no you're
you're right the problem is the
anti-semites don't care about that
right right and the other questions real
quick is about florida it's a bunch of
stuff going on in florida yeah with
they're banning books from the schools
yes uh
they're uh now they've got nazis all
over the place and the republican party
is not not saying anything about it
basically i'm worried about we already
have uh christian nationalists in the
military yes uh you know
michael flynn was just one of them
and uh it's going on as well
and now we got nazis so uh maybe they're
in the military
and it could be pretty bad uh yeah you
know the banning of books is similar to
what happened in germany when they
burned books because they were on german
and now they're doing books because uh
they're
not white or they're not religious
uh
the school board said something last
week about in my area about saying well
if you can't read uh
you know a book in in church you
shouldn't have it in your library
you know that's pretty bad that is
pretty bad it's it's horrible what's
going on in florida the other thing you
didn't mention which we talked about
earlier this week on the bonus show is
that they're moving this don't say gay
bill
through the senate where teachers in
primary school won't be allowed to even
talk at all about sexual orientation or
gender identity and we we of course
understand the homophobic and
transphobic nature of that it's wacky
what's going on in florida i'm actually
i have a couple of invitations for shows
that film in florida and i'm thinking
now that covid cases are down so low i
may do it soon so i may be down there
doing a little investigating of my own
before you know it
well let me know when you come by maybe
we'll meet all right yeah we'll grab an
espresso okay
thank you all right very good there's
marcos from florida yeah i mean it's uh
it's a coveted hellscape but the weather
is nice
one of our sponsors is established
titles if you're looking for a perfect
last minute valentine's day gift check
this out it's funny it's unique and
they're supporting a great cause
established titles is a project based on
the historic scottish custom where
landowners are called lords and ladies
and so established titles lets you
ceremonially
buy as little as one square foot of
dedicated land in aberdeenshire scotland
so that you can call yourself a lord or
lady you get an official certificate
with a crest they let you see exactly
where your spot is located
but in return for each one sold
established titles will plant a tree to
protect the beautiful pristine woodlands
of scotland established titles also
supports global charities like one tree
planted and trees for the future so it's
a fun gift but you're also helping to
support something great and right now
they're having a huge valentine's day
sale on top of that you'll get an extra
10 percent off when you go to establish
titles.com pacman and use the code
pacman the link is down below